because we were i mean if we could have
an honest moment we were about to split
so it's like we were having a
conversation about about splitting yeah
because
and it wasn't even at the point of like
hey
i don't care about you it's just more
like i don't feel anything for you and i
think for me personally is because i
felt like i was going to beat up so much
i had nothing left in me i literally had
nothing left to give because i have
exhausted all my resources and trying to
figure out what i'm doing wrong and for
me at that point was
i don't think i am doing anything wrong
like i in five
four three two one welcome everybody to
another episode of the genius brain
podcast this is our third time shooting
this episode
because mariel is in a really funky mood
today it's called
pre-tom so if you guys don't know what
tom is
thomas time of the month excuse me the
way i
like to explain it is damn it you just
said it i just realized
you're trying to roast me
what i usually like to say is that i'm
sorry for you guys out there named
tom but tom is my other boyfriend that
all of my girlfriends also have and we
like to say
damn tom is at my place right now and
then i'd be like oops sorry he's going
over to your place in the next week or
so
time of the month time of the month and
there's something called
pre-tom where i believe none of the male
friends out there like it it's the all
the side effects you could possibly get
before the actual time arrives so let me
just tell you what happened prior prior
to this podcast all right
so we were shoot we were shooting this
episode and typically with this podcast
it's it's a very fun light conversation
right mary and i usually go back and
forth
all the time this is how we are and i'm
a very jokey jokey person
uh but we recorded 15 minutes of some
other footage which you're not going to
see but the energy was was
wild in this room like it was wild and
really bad
like i'm i'm having a conversation i'm
having a good time we're talking about
you know this funny thing that happened
between us
and she was just dead and not having it
and she looked upset and pissed at me
and i'm like yo what is going on
what is this so i actually had to stop
the podcast and ask her
what the problem is and apparently
i got him so upset that he soaked
through like the leather
chair yo i was getting so upset my
calves started sweating
right like i just the leather chair
right here has
a has a bottle stain of sweat from from
anger and
funny enough that actually cracked me up
so i feel better
i don't know because you upset me i
guess so
i like to upset you well here's the
thing right let me ask you this
and this is for people who are are in
long-term relationships and i think one
of the requirements that we have
although it's very hard to tell when
this is going to happen like for me
i think the biggest reason why i was set
is that i was excited to do the podcast
with her
and she said she was down to do it if
she was in a bad mood
all it would require was her to say
today i'm in an off mood
let's not do it today i didn't get that
so i'm not reading these messages
and i'm coming through and when she's
not in a good mood teasing her is not a
is not a good thing but when she's in a
good mood we're just we're
going back and forth and having a good
time so she didn't tell me she was in a
bad mood
and this podcast we literally just
roast each other all the time not just
her like nick
nick on the previous podcast before or a
couple episodes back
he told the worst story ever and that's
why when you were in the room we were
cracking up
that's what it was we were laughing at
him for like 10 minutes straight and
then he got so nervous he started
sweating
how funny he saw he started getting pit
sweats
his whole shirt was he was getting
nervous you know what's funny though
so before this i had a long day so i was
outside in the porch just swinging
swinging away on my rocking chair which
i love
and david was there next to me for a
whole hour apparently we weren't there
for hour
um and would come in and i thought he
knew that i had a rough day
i'm sure he did but he maybe he thought
he felt he i
felt better afterwards which i think i
might have but not quite enough to get
teased
so i took it personal
and yes here we are shooting this
podcast again for the third time
it's it's just a very odd thing like
when you guys are in a relationship
right
and it's sometimes no matter how long
you're with somebody it's hard to read
relationship
cues even though you've seen somebody
upset multiple times sometimes they hide
it really well
because for her work has been very
stressful right and pandemic
and i'm pretty sure everybody out there
understands this when pandemic hit and
you had to take your office job
at home the work multiplied and i hear
her work all the time and it's and it
gives me anxiety
right because her job is specific to
communication right
yeah and when you're in a group setting
and you're in a conference room with
people
you could just talk to them right there
and now you have to set up multiple
meetings with different people
what if you forget to say something or
somebody else from another department
needs
you to communicate this well now you
have to go ahead and figure out their
block of time where they could receive
it
message them hop on another conference
call and then you're then your work is
extended another six seven hours yeah
it's nuts
it's like those casual moments when you
go grab a coffee or you walk
from one meeting to another meeting
those moments are
so essential and i think we just forgot
how essential those are because there's
so
casual conversations that we could have
but really we're
doing our job and like getting the
answers getting the updates
now we have to literally put time
whether that's like a 30 minute even a
15 15-minute check-in and it you just
never leave your desk
and that's what davey here is outside of
my room because our
house is made out of concrete and you
hear everything she
literally is on conference meetings from
9 00 a.m
till 6 p.m all the time it's it's insane
because i have a bi-monthly meeting for
my
for my franchises right so i i for those
of you guys who are new out there i own
a
a matcha franchise called jumbi matcha
and then
also a another food concept called
shrimp daddy
chichi dango this is definitely
sponsored yeah sponsored by
but we have we have uh bi-monthly
investor meetings right where we talk
about updates
things that we are trying to push for
new products and even that even doing a
30-minute meeting is stressful to me
like sitting there you know with
multiple people in this window having
trying to have a conversation and talk
you do that for like eight hours yeah
it's crazy it's
definitely not the perk of my job
i have to say but it's like the most
thing that we do
during pandemic um so i'm someone who
gets
energy from people and you know my job
is to work with creatives and
i feel like the energy of getting the
artist's creative side of it
you know seeing it in person just like
collaborating
with the creative and production
together is not there it's just like
literally meeting one after another and
i
literally don't have the time to even
talk about feelings whether
you know if people are feeling fine
about what's happening out there in the
world like
yes it's happening but do we have time
to talk no because
every minute now counts for some reason
like
30 minutes like we if you're late
after a minute people are wondering
where the hell you are
like i don't know what happened but i
think we just got used to this like work
from home situation that
people are now accepting what it is
and no longer understanding if like
things are happening
well that's kind of ridiculous too
though because
in in a typical workplace right let's
say you have
people that you have to communicate with
or you have to do work in between
people have office chatter they sit down
they see what you're doing hey what are
you working on how
and then you might have like friendly
conversation for five ten minutes then
you get back to work
that's part of what makes work bearable
having that
that communication when you're in a
cubicle and you're sitting by yourself
all day which now you understand when i
was living
all i did was sit in front of the screen
and write all day that's all i did
right right right right right and now i
do the opposite where the daytime where
the sun is out
i'm outside i bike and at night time i
work because either way if i'm gonna be
in the dark
i might as well do it while the world is
done yeah that's why i just sleep later
than you i'm like forget it
yeah and you get the sun which is so
great and like it's refreshing
i think that's the thing like i miss
being outside
i don't know how editors or people who
are in a dark room all day
they're freaks yeah like i i i have this
huge window in my
room now which i love but it's it's a
step better than what i have before
because i barely had a window to look at
i was in the hotel when i had covey
looking outside the window watching
people do tick-tock dances didn't make
me feel better
it actually made me cry i cried a couple
times in that hotel um
it does make me feel better like when
i'm actually outside just getting some
sunlight
but it's so hard because now
not that people expect you to work
during your break time which is your
lunch time
but people are working during lunch time
because
they want to catch up and it's just so
tiring and i think just mentally it's
been
hard for me and physically i've been
trying to do a lot of things like
work out you know walk around and when i
have the time i try to do that and also
i want to do my hobbies which is like
drawings you know editing like but those
are something that i have to do in that
room in that front of that computer that
i'm there all day so sometimes it's
really hard to get there
and i feel like i'm gonna throw up
sometimes because i'm so overwhelmed
with
just looking at the screen all day well
this is what she was going through today
yes and i didn't know you know because
i'm asking her if she wants to be on
this podcast
so in the previous the previous podcast
that we recorded i was just telling this
really funny story
and it's just this really odd it's not
just her and she took it as me just
making fun of her which typically
it's fine like we tease each other all
the time so
she has this habit which i know of which
is where she talks to herself
right yes and in the middle of the night
i'm trying to sleep and this is this is
one of the weird times where i'm
actually sleeping earlier than she does
but you were talking on the phone with
somebody to really late at night
but i don't know what happened but
imagine the whole the room that we're in
the lights are off and you just see this
bathroom light on
like the slit of light the parameter of
it exactly the perimeter of light which
is the clear sign of a horror movie
and then she just starts
she's like full-on conversation with
herself what i thought was somebody else
because she was playing two roles she
was playing the person that was speaking
and the person that's speaking back damn
i thought he wouldn't bring this up
again
i got a little freaked out and i'm
telling this funny story where i was
scared i actually had a nightmare that
night
that muriel was possessed by a demon
that was talking to her
so that's how scary and scary it was and
then at by the way when we're in bed too
i'm telling her this and she goes she
thinks it's so funny
she's giggling as the lights are off
which isn't helpful
it's not helping she goes are you scared
that's not like hey that's not funny
but don't don't do that and it accepted
my dreams and i had a nightmare well why
didn't you run away
honey you had your moment you have i did
what you get
opportunity to leave i did what any
adult would do
i wrapped myself in my blanket and i hid
and it did nothing
no because i'm still here you know how
petty this girl is and so
then so i also talk to myself here and
there right when i'm writing stand-up
new jokes or whatever or i'm kind of
working out ideas and thoughts that i
want to put down on paper by the way
i've heard this guy talk
so so much
but how do i talk to myself though it's
scary as if you're chanting something
you're like memorizing to chant
something later on like put a hat on and
there's like a pot of like disgusting
stuff
just like you're just being ridiculous
no that's what i think i feel like
you're just chatting away
sometimes you seem like a crazy guy
because the thing is he has emotion to
it
and i'm like because i'm writing
something
i don't know that i didn't know you did
i told you this early on the day
early on in our relationship and i'm
like i don't know why he's like
but that's and also too i'm also running
lines because i'm auditioning
so i'm running these lines in my head
he's either saying he's running lines to
audition
running live stories and it's true
it's um okay yeah sure me too i'm
writing stories
i'm writing you're literally not in them
you're literally not you
literally refer to yourself in the third
person you're not
you're not writing a script actually
show me your script
nothing show me your script you show me
your script
i'll show you what that i'll show you a
hundred script right now yeah you should
show me right now
beat your ass right now totally beat
your ass
excuse me no violence here okay we got
kids watching
there is no do you even know what i do
for a living no i don't that's
the problem no that's not the case so
you want to hear how how petty this girl
is
so just party said i'm petty oh wait no
you don't okay never mind go ahead
okay you know the previous podcast your
energy was way low now that she's
through the roof you triggered me let me
let me tell you with this girl let me
tell you the pettiness
when you're a butt naked yeah relax hold
on a second
set it up right before you spit that
water out your mouth this is leather
seats
that water will soak right there that's
water you got sweat on there that's
formula
this girl is so petty she's this woman
is like actively trying to catch me talk
to myself
i'm in the bathroom i get done with the
shower and in the shower i'm like
running these funny lights
it happens like nine out of ten okay
hold on a second
so i'm i'm literally i'm like i'm like
eminem
in an eight mile but i'm butt naked over
my sink um
and i'm sitting there just kind of
mumbling that's not what i thought about
okay
like these things that i'm butt naked
dick out everything and i just hear
this door open slightly and she looks at
me and she goes
see you do it too i'm like the
creepiest way ever how could you the
most pettiest woman ever
i'm naked she couldn't even wait for me
to put my clothes back on
nope cause you know why i was outside
the hallway
doing you know having my own business
and all of a sudden here
so
she gets this random accent i've heard
of that before before
it's because i can't close my mouth
i've heard of him before so i go to the
bathroom and sure enough he's talking to
himself in life
hello my christina aguilera what's going
but you on like you're chanting so i'm
like uh-huh
i could you know if i knew this day
would come i would have recorded every
time i saw you
talking to yourself before we continue
my lovely brain farts this podcast is
brought to you by purple
have you been sleeping some of the worst
sleeps in your life maybe your back
hates you as much as you hate yourself
well love yourself by respecting your
back with a purple mattress
before my purple mattress i was sleeping
on a quilted bag of sadness a tuck to
square
shame spring-filled torture box and like
birdman once said you ain't gonna
disrespect me no
mo remember if you sleep hot like me
purple technology keeps you cool
supports your back
sides hips neck shoulders if your
mattress ain't supporting you like
purple you need to
leave him purple really is comfort for
an uncomfortable world
right now you'll get 10 off any order of
200
or more go to purple.com gv10 and use
promo code gb10 that's purple.com
gp10 promo code gb10 for 10
off any order of 200 or more purple.com
gb ted promo code gb10 turns apply
i don't but it's not really talking to
myself though i'm reciting lines
how is reciting lions be talking about
that's what you could say
fine let's all believe that what does
your
sweater say tigger okay no
okay i know
do you know who i am i i hey i'm finding
out new things apparently you talked to
spirits in the middle of the night
you know what i do so you better watch
out what are you going to do what is the
spirit going on
i keep talking to myself that's what i'm
going to do you're freaking weird dude
hey here's your opportunity the door is
open
it's not it's literally closed all
righty
[Laughter]
case close you know what i've always
wanted to ask you
let me ask you something this is a very
serious question not really serious but
what you had an idea of boyfriend
okay hold the [ __ ] on wait what's going
on someone's attacking me right off the
jump let me finish my damn sentence
okay a perfect man
i can talk about that hold on a second
okay so you had an idea
okay well i don't have feelings now
either i have
so you had an idea of the type of man
that you wanted to be with right
well i wasn't far okay yeah you're
laughing already right
and i'm i'm your first serious boyfriend
yes now clearly
from the so when we were first going out
i i know the type of woman that she
physically finds attractive right
what was that and first you had a
picture of daniel henny
on your phone who doesn't have a picture
of daniel henry for like the first
year it was a very long time and i'm
like we've been together for a year now
i think you should change that
background
but it was a long time i was i couldn't
show it to my family all right i got to
make sure that they know i still love
daniel honey
okay well you had an idea of a person
that you wanted to be with right
and then obviously i am not daniel henny
and then we have right did you did you
was there ever a point when i when i got
really big because when you first met me
i was maybe like 230 pounds 35 pounds so
maybe 15 pounds heavier no
about like 50 pounds heavier than i am
now right and then i blew up to be like
280.
was there ever a point when when i
gained a lot of weight that you found me
completely repulsive
be honest you could be honest i could be
really honest you could be a hundred
percent
no really because i was in love with you
oh this girl tried to get brownie points
for real
after she hurt my feelings in the first
15 minutes of the other podcast
hey it's not like i didn't you didn't
you noticed it though right you noticed
i
noticed it i noticed it and you know i
approached it here and there but not
really because you were
you were you were busy you were doing
what you got to do you were doing your
food thing
you were doing your audition and you
were
really busy and the one thing that you
had fun was eating laid out with your
friends
yeah and you were literally having tacos
almost every night
and i remember that because i was like i
can't eat tacos again
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah and then you
know when we meet up which usually will
be over the weekend
all you wanted to do was lay on the bed
because you were tired
yeah so i knew that you were off
and you yes you were getting bigger but
i don't think
uh i think
i was already in a stage where it's
beyond the physical look
so cause i remember we went out like at
a beach one time and i remember we took
this picture too we took a selfie but i
remember that day i was like
holy cow i am in love with this guy and
regardless how big he is
that's kind of funny it's just crazy
because
uh yeah when i remember like you were
big but then that wasn't like my
but my only concern was your health yeah
it wasn't like me being less attracted
to was it really hard for you to bring
it up to me
because you you never you you never
really
i mean there was one time where i think
that we got into a big fight when we
first started and i remember you started
crying it was literally in my bed and it
was because you made
a you were kind of like um
i felt that and it could have been just
my personal issues with my health
at the time but it was something that
had to do with my weight
right and was this when you were big
this is early on this is like our first
year in our relationship
and i just remember like i told you i
was like you
make me feel like unattractive it was
something along those lines
and and i think that when i said i
remember you started
bawling like it was the first time i
ever saw you cry oh i don't remember
this
you were literally in my bed and you
were
you were sobbing like like straight up
korean drama style
and i was like yo what the [ __ ]
and you know and i think for you you
said that you didn't like the way that
made me feel because you said that's how
people used to make you feel and now you
were doing the same to me
you know so maybe that had a little bit
to do with it and it wasn't anything i
don't think you ever really attacked me
it's just i took it really personal
right
because i had issues with my health that
i just kind of chose to ignore
and just something like you know if
you're asian american out there right
and i'm pretty sure you have in other
cultures too
but the conversation and topic about
your weight is so hard to circumvent
when you talk to
an older generation oh yeah always talk
about your weight
the way you look and it has nothing to
do with your health they never mentioned
health
no they always talk about how it makes
you look and they bring it up as
if it's okay to say like hey you got
chunky
yeah you know i used to always hear that
when i go to korea i'd be like
oh you got so chunky again here have
some tomatoes
yeah it's it's very weird like korean
people and their obsession with weight
and so yeah it was a very sensitive
subject for me because my parents would
always be on my back about my weight
right and i think my parents didn't know
how to address it really properly
because they weren't speaking my
language per se
so when my parents or my dad would uh
[ __ ] on me about my weight
he would never do it in the perspective
of like listen like
it's not good for you you know what i
mean like i'm not asking you to lose a
crap ton of weight but
just you know try to get a little
healthier he would never do it
encouragingly right
he would always say like don't you want
to look good you know and that's how he
would say things
so when people would talk about my
weight in that sense i always converted
into comedy i made jokes about it
yeah and it allowed me to take that type
of angst and put it somewhere else right
because personal image when you're a
young kid it affects you a lot
yeah you want to be the hot guy you want
to be the popular kid
you want to be the cool kid and maybe
i mean now because of the like the body
positivity movement
there is more acceptance of people in
different with different body sizes
yeah when we were younger yeah it was it
was never that case there was only
specific body
type yeah that was like considered dope
but now you see thicker girls
and it's which i love i love the variety
of it
yeah yeah but yeah when you were big
though i think
when it did come to a situation i'm like
damn this might not be healthy i think i
i think i remember that just because the
way that you were eating like i couldn't
eat with you
and i think that triggered me of
thinking like
it needs to be brought up but like i
wanted to bring it up where you will
listen
right yeah yeah yeah you're as like oh
not a thing you know
um because it was hard i think like the
hard part for me too was that
i didn't want to openly admit it but i
couldn't do
the activities that you were doing
because i wasn't physically capable
right yeah you said you had a hard time
sleeping and your ankles were hurting
like i couldn't do it well now my knees
all messed up because of the way i
worked out but
but you know but the hard part about
that was you know mentally i felt like
i could do everything but when i would
try to do it it was so damn hard
you know but i'm never going to admit it
i'm just going to you know
swallow my pride wow huh why because i
have a perception of myself when i was
more fit
you know in my mind so you were a bigger
head that's why
in my mind i'm a lot more fit than i
actually am yeah you know so it's like
oh today's an off day
right and it never clicked for me that
the reason why i didn't want to go
biking or
well i didn't want to go biking because
i got clipped by a car in k-town and
that should traumatize me
but um nice job yeah i didn't want to go
biking or i didn't want to do like these
other extracurricular activities
because at the end of the day it would
just kill me it was so hard it was so
difficult to do it
and i never really registered as being
difficult because the task was
was really hard because i was fat it was
just that the task is just difficult and
everybody can't do this
it's not but it wasn't everybody it was
just me well that's what happens like
you rationalize things that you don't
want to face
when there's issues that are being faced
that you that you know are right there
it's easier for you to make an excuse
than for you to address
your problems then how did how did it
click later on david gawkins it was a
podcast
i know before that that's when you're
like i need to address it but
i know i just i just had this moment it
was this really funny moment and i
thought
i said this joke a million times but it
i say it as a joke but it actually
happened you and i were going out to eat
and i made a comment about a fat couple
and then you looked at me and you said
you're
just as fat as that i was like oh did i
say that i was like
what a [ __ ]
you know and then i remember that kind
of stuck with me and i'm like
am i just as fat as those people like i
know i'm fat right
but i'm like i'm like fat like them like
super out of shape just
shoving food in my face and then little
things started to click
like i remember just walking down the
stairs i could feel everything jiggle
i'm like yo this is a little odd my
clothes wouldn't fit none of it stuff
and it was very proof on it
it was super uncomfortable and then i
listened to this podcast with david
goggins and he kind of got me motivated
and after that i just started dropping
the weight oh so what's that
i thought it was um because you saw
yourself in a video where you're just
like
what the hell was this guy i noticed
that i just didn't
i didn't care enough though it was more
like oh you know the camera always adds
100 pounds so it doesn't
oh my god you know the camera always
makes you look bigger than you actually
are
you know yeah but that's so weird
because like i feel i feel girls have a
bigger capacity to love somebody than
sometimes a guy does
i think so yeah i mean can you because
if you gain 30 pounds
30 40 pounds i think i'd be fine really
yeah
i don't know i like but you know i like
thicker girls though
like there's thicker girls but there's
like i know what
yeah like i think there is thick there's
thick but there's
chunky like yeah i don't know unhealthy
look yeah i can't be
yeah well you can't be too you wouldn't
be morbidly obese like i was though like
i was morbidly obese
you know what i mean i think if i was as
big as you
i don't think my body could handle that
exactly you wouldn't you would be dead
that's what it would be but if you say
you gained 40 pounds i probably i
i'd be like oh she looked thick that's
all but i like thicker girls though so
like i've dated thicker women
it's it's not a big thing hmm i don't
know i
like because i know like you're one of
the smaller girls i've dated
like my body frame wise is smaller
but i know there are bigger frames who
are thicker
but not necessarily like
fatter if that makes sense so i i
i understand if you're attracted to like
bigger
shape like but not fat
no i'm i think your perception of what
fat is to me is different like for a
girl
like when a girl has like rolls or
whatever here and there it's not really
fat to me
that's like what if it had like no neck
well i'm well you might be morbidly
obese at that point but like thicker
girls
too where there's like rolls here a
little stretch mark here that i don't
really care about that that's actually
kind of nice to me
it's just how i grew up like women in my
neighborhood were thicker like that's
just what i saw that's what i grew up
with
so it's just and i do believe that a
majority of women do look like that
especially specifically in the united
states
yeah so it's like something that i'm i'm
used to i mean among my
quote unquote american friends i am on
the smaller side
so yeah and you know what too it's you
know i'm not speaking about this from
you know what beauty standard standards
are in person in terms of what my change
in my life was
it just had to do with the fact that i
felt like [ __ ] and i couldn't ignore it
anymore
yeah you know and i'm glad you changed
it because
it's hard now too even going to hawaii
when i gained that 10 pounds i worked so
hard to drop like eight it took me two
and a half weeks and i dropped like
seven seven ish pounds seven eight
pounds but that was hard
but i feel better though and i still
haven't even lost all the weight that i
gained within the eight days in hawaii i
still have three more pounds to lose
and then i feel a little normal there
was that one time and i will remember
that onigiri photo
in little tokyo where i saw your jawline
it was the first day i saw your video
you went jawlines dude what is that uh
so i don't know ever since i was a
i was young i had a thing about drawing
so have you seen thanos
huh thanos from marvel who's thanos you
don't know who thanos is
where's my damn phone this is gonna get
you horny watch this dude let me show
you he could
continue your story oh so like uh so
when i was in middle school i was into a
guy named
tom welling who's the superman from
smallville he had a
nice jawline and i think that's where it
came i was just like oh
that jawline though let me show you let
me show you the best jawline ever dude
this is from marvel this is thanos this
might get you
looking that's a jawline right there
that's a chin line not a jawline
that's the longest chin line ever
no it's a jawline it's different that is
a beautiful jawline
daniel honey house it has a very nice
job my brain farts this podcast is
brought to you by skillshare
listen let me cut to the chase i know
you're like me you have hobbies you have
goals and a bunch of things you want to
learn and try but you don't know where
to get the right information
or let alone start and yeah you can
search online for hours for the right
class but i'm telling you stop that and
get skillshare
skillshare is an online learning
community that offers
membership with meaning with so much to
explore
real projects create and the support of
other fellow
creatives skillshare empowers you to
accomplish real growth and that's why i
love them and listen
the course i'm checking out right now is
actually called the youtube success
script shoot and edit by marcus brownlee
he's actually one of my favorite online
creators and i've been doing this a long
time but i can always learn
from the greats and that is mkbhd i
love his stuff so i can learn a lot from
so remember
explore your creativity at
skillshare.com brain and get a free
trial of premium membership that's
skillshare.com
brain i don't know and also i look at
myself when i when i was younger i was
like do i have a nice job
i have a very nice jawline do i
what what is the what is probably the
the hardest part about quarantine for
you
in terms of us for in our relationship
because
i think the quarantine definitely tested
our relationship a lot
like yeah you know and
you know in your case too i don't know
if you're comfortable about talking
about this right
and we'll cut it out if you're not but
you had a lot of personal stuff that you
had to go through
right and you know for me it was very
difficult because
you know during this quarantine
everybody was talking about their
relationships being tested
and i knew it was going to come yeah and
i've even mentioned this on jk news
before where i said the reason why you
and i work out so well is because you
and i have two very separate lives
yes and we get to meet up and talk about
it yes and that was that part was
taken out of our relationship it was
literally stripped from us
and yes it was hard to deal with you
know
and for you too a lot of things were
kind of
in this quarantine a lot of this was
brought up for everybody there are
demons that we didn't have to face
because we weren't
we didn't have time to sit in our house
and think about these things we had so
many other distractions that kind of
kind of push away a lot of our personal
issues quarantine didn't allow for that
and we had too much time to think and
allow for these thoughts to kind of eat
us up inside
right and so in your case
i was having a lot of trouble too
because
i'm kind of i'm kind of somebody who
because i went through that the fire and
brimstone of
this this situation already my
quarantine already happened once when i
was 280 pounds
and i was staying at home um
i was kind of like depressed and all i
had to do was work out and lose his
weight
so i knew how to combat this stuff i had
to be active
actually i was kind of curious like how
quarantine has changed your
life because obviously for me like i've
you know a lot of things have stripped
away including like going to work but
for you like
you were still able to work around you
know seeing
friends and like work people i mean
you still had that connection i
completely lost it
it changed my life in terms of i don't
have a traveling show anymore like i
used to travel for work all the time i
did stand up i was doing college shows
all that stuff was taken away from me so
for me i adapted by i picked up a hobby
i picked the biking oh it only took
seven years
only seven years i'm here now i will
never let it go
and now i'm dusting her ass when i bike
so we don't even bike together by the
way folks
it's different because she you she likes
it she her our weather conditions are so
different
but we i i picked up a hobby in order to
combat
everything else right because i figured
out that i actually need to be outside
and i need to be active
and another thing that was taken away
from was kickboxing mm-hmm kickboxing
was completely taken out
that was my life like kickboxing was my
thing yeah and so
i decided to for me anyways to just pick
up biking just to keep active and kind
of figure things out
and i started walking again i was
walking like eight nine ten minutes yeah
and so there was ways for me to figure
it out and so i was figuring out on my
own time
my happiness yeah right and then and i
think for you because you had personal
turmoil with your own issues of
happiness
i can't fix that for you right and i
think when we were going through our
personal relationship
you know at the time when i was telling
you this it kind of made you feel
that when i said hey i can't make you
happy like i haven't changed like
i'm figuring this out it made me it made
you feel like i was putting the blame on
you
yeah right but what i was really trying
to say was you are responsible for your
own happiness
yeah i can only support you in your
happiness and help you figure it out and
give you an
ear but i can't be i can't be the enemy
and your friend at the same time it
doesn't make sense
you know yeah i had a hard time i don't
know what happened like there was like a
switch later on and i don't know where
where and when that happened and i think
it's honestly when
we moved in together because i'm all
about so i
you know prior to living with you i
lived with a lot of other housemates
um and kind of worked around like you
know making sure that we're all just
like in a happy
situation because we all need a
compromise and i think my
goal was that let's just compromise
everything when we move in together
obviously i had my needs and my wants
but i think overall like i try to like
i'm a people pleaser it's what i do in
my job too like
i do what i can to please people and so
i think i applied that to our
relationship when we moved in
um and then you know we moved to a
couple places
and one thing that really did help me
before quarantine was that i got to
um close that chapter while i'm at work
you know like while i'm at work i have
this whole different life that i don't
need to
worry about what this person is going to
think
you know how to compromise like you're
not
i'm just there to be myself and do my
job i'm so good at my job right
and so i have this confident of just
like
having a good time with friends
co-workers
you know and then i work out as well at
work you know there's a gym
or like with friends we would go and do
outdoor activities
and then i come back and then i'll be
with you again and then with you
i think because we're so new living
together it was always a little bit
sensitive for me of like
understanding what works for us
um because clearly we both have very
different
lifestyle in the inside of the house you
know like the first thing the obvious
thing would be do we keep the toilet
seat up or down that was the first move
on from that let's continue
no i'm saying like we've gone a long way
though like i
you've done really well putting it down
and i've been very good
not go crazy if it's up
so that said quarantine came around and
i think in the beginning
i had some leisure time to like do what
you did so while you go out i go out and
like
you know go for a run do my exercise and
i think it really helps
in sense of like you know making sure
that we don't go
insane and then at a certain point i
didn't have that time you know while
you're out there and at about and like
doing what you got to do
i was trapped in my room from morning
till night
um unless i have to go to the bathroom
which i would run it would be right next
door but like i didn't even have the
time to go to the bathroom
you know and i was just literally stuck
to this computer
all day and out of
and then i realized that i started
losing a lot of weight sure some people
are like oh you're so lucky you're
losing weight on quarantine because
everyone's gaining weight
no i was losing it because i was so
stressed out which i
never ever had issue before i've never
lost weight because i was stressed out
so that was just a weird part
um and i think that shows how stressed
out i was because then
the next thing i know is that when i do
have the free time i'm always at the
clinic
i'm at a different clinic every day
trying to figure out what's wrong with
my body because my body started to
shut down and it's just so much pain on
my body that
obviously it's not like it's not like i
broke my body
but it's just this subtle pain that
would just never go away it's like these
like you know constant migraine where
it's not like
super big but it's just there all the
time
that you slowly get agitated and
irritated
and it sucks the life out of you later
on and then you become action you become
this agitated person you lose that
that bright side of yours and i think i
just got in
got sucked into this like dark hole
where i didn't know how to release that
i didn't think that was the hard part
too because
any any girl that's been in a
relationship with me knows that i am an
over communicator meaning that i
like to ask questions right and so i
think like me
asking you i think like the frustrating
part for me was
when i would ask you why it kind of made
me seem that i was being dismissive of
what you were feeling
but i just didn't understand so i had to
ask why and i'm like well why
why is it that you feel this way why is
it that way and the response that you
kept giving me was you just need to be
nice
and i couldn't figure out what that
meant i don't know what that means i
need to know
why like what am i doing so the one
thing that was always around
was david and it's david and the
apartment right and our apartment i have
to say like we didn't think that we
would be in the house 24 7. so it was a
place where we just come home
sleep rest and then yeah yeah but it
became
our life right and you know
david is all there all day and i'm there
all day so if a person or human being is
in the house all day things are gonna
get messed around
things are going to be moved around our
place was small small for
the amount of stuff that i have because
i have equipment and stuff yeah and also
we have two bikes we have no garage we
have no
yeah it wasn't really meant to it felt
like a storage
yeah but i guess just
my out i don't know what it was but then
that triggered me that was my trigger
of like things that i'm in place things
are messy
like i can't get out of this box i felt
like i was inside a box all the time
and david was there to take my anger
basically
he was the one and only who's there to
absorb my anger
my agitation and it just built up on him
and he was trying to figure out
why i'm feeling this because i'm just
inside a box in a room
all day and i come down and like being
mean to him and he didn't understand
that
which i also didn't understand because i
didn't think that i was doing it but
it was just seeping out so bad
yeah it felt like i no matter what move
i was making i was doing something wrong
and so you know for me personally i have
to take a step back and think like okay
what am i doing wrong like is this like
am can i
try things and so you know things would
be addressed and he goes try this try
that
i would do it and nothing would get
better so i'm like this is not a me
problem now this is her problem
yeah and it was hard for her to take me
saying that to her because it makes you
feel as if
she has nobody on her side it's like
well so it's just all my fault and
that's what it can feel like when that
comes off but
i was at my wit's end i didn't know what
to do i didn't have anything else left
in me because i'm literally just
existing at this point
you know and you know for for us because
i i've done like there i've and
you know better help is a sponsor of
this podcast right and i i talk about
better help a lot just because
i do like online offline counseling
online counseling or off
versus off-site counseling because i'm
somebody who deals with anxiety
and sometimes like talking over talking
with somebody over the phone it's a lot
easier for me
and so for mariel if you're okay with
sharing this like she started
doing online counseling as well and that
really helped out because
for how i see it anyways our
relationship has been so much better
since
because there are things that you could
talk to
about with that person that you can with
me or even your best friend sometimes
yeah no i loved it i mean i think the
way
that this the situation where we're
having that conversation you mentioning
like
taking a therap having a therapist i
think just the situation
and the conversation we're having put me
off wrong or
it set me off wrong and i was just like
in denial because it sounded like
i have you're the problem yeah i'm the
problem
um but nonetheless i still i was like i
got nothing else to lose i'm like i feel
like at my
bottom right because we were i mean if
we could have an honest moment we were
about to split so it's like we were
having a conversation
about about splitting yeah because and
it wasn't even at the point of like
hey i don't care about you
it's just more like i don't feel
anything for you anything for me
personally is because i felt like i was
getting beat up so much
i had nothing left in me i literally had
nothing left to give because i have
exhausted all my resources and trying to
figure out what i'm doing wrong and for
me at that point was
i don't think i am doing anything wrong
like i've i've
done everything that i thought i did on
the checklist i've reduced x amount of
things
and i'm want i want her to be happy and
i think for her
when it came to the therapy the the
therapy idea
like one of the things that she didn't
know which i didn't discuss with her she
goes well
well how about we do couples therapy and
i was like i need you to trust and this
is what i truly believe
it's like i'm down for couples therapy
100 but
i wanted her to do therapy first because
i needed her to trust the process first
because i've been to therapy i did it
for two years straight because i had
anger issues
so i had to go through anger management
and therapy for it because i was a very
very violent kid
and it was because of the household that
i grew up because of therapy i actually
fixed the relationship i had with my
father
um not so much the therapist dealing
with my parental
issues per se but dealing with my anger
and learning how to empathize
transferred over to how i dealt with my
father
yeah right and so i know therapy works
right i truly believe in it
and i think the hard part is is that you
know i think couples therapy is okay
but having a personal therapist for you
to talk out your thoughts before we meet
our couple's therapist would have been
the best
you know because trusting the process is
really important
when you when you have that therapist
and you can have a conversation because
if we go into it together
it feels a little volatile for me
because at that point i just didn't have
it in me left i didn't have it
yeah you know so if he went to couples
therapy i felt like i wouldn't have been
honest
about it i would have just had nothing
left to give i would just sat there and
just
one ear out the other you know yeah so
um
fortunately fortunately i found an
amazing therapist that
actually worked out so well like i
i always say that she's very magical i
i'm so glad in my first trial well
technically it was my second try
but it was my first try recently where
you know i just picked one and then just
have to
happen to be a great one who it's weird
like you don't even
have to she doesn't even ask much
it just she just says the right
questions i guess maybe the right
keywords where it triggers me and keeps
talking and talking and there was at
this one point
where one of the conversation was that
uh what makes me happy and we're just
having a conversation conversation and
it turns out
that my happiness depends on david
so if david's unhappy i'm unhappy if
david's happy i'm happy
and she was she just kept looking at me
my therapist just looked at me like your
happiness depends on your partner and i
was like yeah
it does and
it took me a second or so to process i'm
like
holy cow when did i lose my
independency independence independence
independency i love that word dude let's
cut that out we got to keep that in
because you're a rapper now dude that's
a rapper word
compromisation yeah that's right yo
what's up this is my new album
independency independency
independence um i was like holy cow when
did i lose it
uh and the crazy thing is is like i've
kind of lightly touched on the subject
with her
but obviously the therapist can say it
in better words than me but my words
were
you need to focus on your self-care you
know i was like literally saying
self-care self-care
self-care yeah when i remember and then
you went to the you went into the uh
the the supermarket with becky and you
went self-care
out of nowhere that was some of the
because of you yeah i was telling you
about stuff i don't want to credit you
on that i remember that
yes and then you went you went and then
becky told me that you went into the uh
to the super and you screamed self-care
because i was telling you about taking
like self-care like i'm not responsible
for you personally my therapist
no this is what i told you like uh i
don't remember before your therapist
right but this is what i'm saying how
like when you have an impartial third
party they're
able to communicate it to you better
because i'm also the source of your
anger
so you can't no it doesn't come out the
same way
so that's what i'm saying like i can't
help you yes you know i literally you
are
helpless that's what i'm saying helpless
man
um all right but that said uh
i think that's the one thing that really
shook me is that
trying to remember when when did this
start when did it start that
that i had to depend my happiness on
this guy and if
it made me frustrated not mad but
frustrated because i didn't want that to
be the case like
and i'm just such an
independent woman before i met you like
i was just like
[ __ ] everyone else like i'm first it's
what i want to do and now i became like
i don't even care about myself like what
is it do should i do this to make you
happy
and that just made me so mad which is so
odd for me because i've never expected
that from her at all
like because i'm a people pleaser that's
what it is it's that it comes down to
that
with my parents too like i do things to
please them you know i went to
certain school because that pleased them
i went to certain company because that
pleased them and
that's just i i
hunger i hunger
i hunger for um
for uh gratification i guess
not gratification what do you call it um
what do you call it oh i know what the
word you're talking about that you
it's um it's like confirmation like
confirmation
affirmation affirmation i hunger for
affirmation which is so interesting
right because i'm i'm i'm typically the
opposite
i don't need others approvals i need to
prove it myself
right so when i do personal projects or
what no matter what i do
i need to enjoy it first [ __ ] what
somebody else thinks do i like it first
and it just turns out the things that i
like typically other people like too so
but if i don't personally like it i
don't give a [ __ ] if you like it or not
i could care less like i could put out a
song right and then they're like yo that
song's dope i'm like that's cool i
[ __ ] hate it i'll trash it
it doesn't matter if you like it because
it's for me first because i
uh that's what you know i think artistry
has to come for yourself first
yeah when you think about the business
sense you're trying to sell your art
there's that whole side too but when i
create and i do things for my personal
happiness
my opinion matters the most whether
somebody thinks it's trash it's
terrible if it's good or bad [ __ ] your
opinion
i need to like it first you can have
your opinion after i have my own
you know so i like i've never expected
i it was so weird when you told me you
came to that realization because then it
made me think like
did i did i do this like did i make her
feel that she needed to please me
but in my personal opinion i didn't feel
like it was because i never been like
that like i've always just kind of done
my own thing
and it was something that was
frustrating for my parents growing up
because
you know they're like you don't care
what other people think and it was
frustrating because my father's a pastor
we have this korean community that
gossips all the time yeah
so i just kind of always live my own
life and i've been able to kind of
you know i've had my stages where i'm
super sad and everything else
but i've always been able to pick myself
up because i've kind of
put my happiness on my own personal
responsibility yeah and it's been a lo
it kind of allows me to um
just be happy you know yeah i mean i
don't know if i could go com
i feel like we're all in like polar
opposite when it comes to those well you
know i'm kind of extreme though i'm kind
of i'm really extreme
i'm a little extreme you are like and i
think that's that's another thing like
i'm i'm such a normal average
person you know i mean like i'm on the
spectrum of it i'm so
average that i have a partner who's
not so average and it could be a good
thing and also a bad thing
in a sense of like you're so extreme
that like
i i feel like
i judge myself even that much more not
because of who you are just because of
who i
am like because i'm so much of a people
pleaser
that extreme of yours is even more
extreme to me
do you know what i mean yeah yeah yeah
yeah like someone could be just like
you know if i have a typical nice guy my
people pleasing side wouldn't be as like
crazy of wanting to please that person
because it's so easy
because i'm also very opinionated about
things but it doesn't
it doesn't really mean anything it's a
thought everything's everything is a
thought
right so for example let's say um
if i cook something right and
it's not that great i beat myself up
more than somebody else will beat up my
dish
what if everybody said was good i don't
care i don't like it you're not getting
it again
you know do you know what i mean cause
remember there's like stuff that i cook
it's good i'm like i'm not serving this
like i'm not serving this dish i don't
like it you're not going to get it you
have a strong opinion i'm the opposite
i am such a wishy-washy girl maybe it's
the gemini in me but like
oh my god i'd be like this oh god yeah
like for example like if i get an outfit
right i'm like i think this looks cool
and no i'm like oh i think this outfit
looks ugly and if someone says oh that's
really cute i'll be like oh really maybe
it is cute after all like
i'm such an easy go not easy going what
is it very wishy-washy
um so i like to have someone who affirms
my opinion
yeah i think that's where back again i
come together and you and i are
different like i don't care if you
affirm it or not like i'm pretty much
good i can live
with or without it so i've been so easy
i could go anywhere with basketball
basketball shorts and a t-shirt you know
like i don't care where i'm going
this is just who i am you are someone
who wants
you don't care as in like i'll go
wherever you go
you want someone to make the direction
you want the someone to
um uh what is it uh decide the final
decision
yeah i'm someone who
i'm kind of on the same side but if
someone asks me to make the final
decision
i start to hesitate and this kind of
makes sense too so for example
when we uh mary and i went to paris for
tiff and casey's uh
wedding so if you guys don't know if you
guys are listening for the first time
tiffany and casey are also youtubers
they um
they uh they got married in paris it was
like the dream wedding or whatever
um muriel set up a whole itinerary we
couldn't hit certain things and it was
stressing her out
right um and there were things and the
things that she was taking me to
she and i both haven't been to but i
didn't like it and it personally hurt
her
and for me i couldn't compute that
because it's like well yeah you set up
the itinerary
i'm not telling you i'm having a bad
time i'm not telling you the day is
ruined i'm just saying like ah this is
whatever
which happens when you have new
experiences you're not gonna love
everything but it was hard for her to
hear that because it was such a personal
blow yeah because the people pleasing
site was coming out it's like this
person isn't pleased
but in my mind i'm like you don't have
to like it either we both don't have to
like this
yeah just because it's on the list it
doesn't mean it has to be liked which
makes sense it totally means i'm like
you're right
you're right and i think i don't know
what it is i think it's just like
i maybe i was hoping for the best it's
like hope for the best that i work hard
to look for these like you know quote
unquote good food by the way yelp sucks
and google sucks too when it comes to
paris oh my gosh like we went to one
restaurant that
on yelp that said it was amazing we go
in there and it was a freaking like
frozen plate it was terrible the food
was
[ __ ] it was so expensive trip
advisory piece of [ __ ]
well that said like i think before i
arrived there like i was hoping it would
be
like perfect plan and i'm not a
perfectionist but like i always hope for
the
hope it would be i guess i don't know
when it comes to that she she has a lot
of qualities that i kind of wish i had
in myself
like because of my anxiety i sometimes i
feel like i choose to ignore things and
go with the flow because when i focus on
it too much
it becomes very highly apparent about
the things i'm not doing right mm-hmm
and so that's what i have and that
aggravates my anxiety so i've chose to
ignore it
problem with that is that you sometimes
you just don't get things done the right
way
you know and that's what i run into a
lot it's
where i'm i'm trying to balance out a
little bit of both right yeah
because for example like planning out
podcasts and topics is something that i
should be doing on the daily if i'm
taking this very seriously yeah
i tend to not do that and you're so
blessed because you could improv well
that's where your experience comes in
yeah but you know this podcast could
probably be a lot better if i planned it
oh yeah i'm sure it would have but hey
you're a one-man business
you can only do so much right um but
that said like if i had
so funny enough i do have friends who
are just like me or even more extreme
than i am when it comes to like going on
a trip and planning things
i am you in that group yeah and when i'm
in those groups i'm like
if i don't need to do it i won't do it i
will go with the flow and i love doing
that because you know why
i know that they have a plan and i can
see the plan it makes me very
also for me too because like control is
also another factor for anger for me
right
so if i'm trying to take control of
something it's just not popping off
right
i'm going to get angry yeah you know
it's something that i kind of learned to
like going with the flow was also
something i learned with like anger
management not trying to control
everything the only thing i could do is
control my emotions and myself
right so like there was another example
and i remember
i think it's true she and i are polar
opposites because when we first started
going out too i remember i had to drop
her off at the airport
and uh she was going to be late because
there was construction on the freeway
and she was just kind of going on this
long conversation in the car like what's
going to happen if she doesn't make it
and i've learned to do the opposite
where i was telling her
whether you complain whether you're
anxious angry or not
we're still going to get there on the
same time nothing is going to change
so you have to accept that and then you
know she got there on time
and when we when we kind of focus on the
stuff that we literally can't change
it's a waste of time we cannot change we
cannot change the fact that there's
construction on the freeway
we cannot change the fact that you're
going to be late we can only do our best
that or we can only hope
that you can make your flight on time
yeah and that's it because the more we
put our energy into things
that literally serve us no purpose we
have wasted our time we have wasted our
happiness
yeah my my goal in life is just to be
happy and it's a struggle
happiness is work people like people
don't understand that happiness is
[ __ ] work you have to want to choose
to stay
in this world and be happy for it to
happen some people are just so
[ __ ] stupid that they're happy all
the time and i know a few people like
that
where they're [ __ ] bimbos and dits
and i'm not talking this is not sex
oriented i'm talking about like dude
dude bimbos
like like marbles in their brains and
sometimes
i am jealous of them yeah it is true the
less you know the more happy you are
that is very true and i think during
this quarantine
it's one of those things i'm like are we
ever gonna get back to how it was and if
so how long is it gonna take
is it worth for me to wait for that time
or is it
a turning point for me because i feel
like
i've discovered so much about certain
things in my life
perspective that i'm wondering should i
take
should i take this turning point and
move on with what i've learned or should
i hope for the
best on the you know that things will
come back to normal and then have my
normal life again
i don't think you should wait for
anything like you just do whatever
you're doing
i don't even go that far to think is
everything going to go back to normal
the normal is whatever the normal is and
i'm just going to function how i
function i'll figure my way around it
right that's the only thing you could do
there are people on this quarantine and
pandemic that
adapted really really well and they took
this
time as an opportunity to kind of level
up or figure the way around
this stuff right yeah and there's other
people who are just coasting
that's that's the idea of not trying to
control things that you cannot change
yeah these things are not in your hands
you could only do what's best for you
and figure that out that's it
that's the only thing you can do yeah
right
yeah this definitely this quarantine has
made you realize that you can only plan
so much and hold on to things so much
that's everything everything is like
that
here's the thing you know what's
guaranteed in this world is death death
is guaranteed
that's the only thing that's guaranteed
yeah what you do with your time on this
earth is very very important maybe not
to everybody else but for you
because the moment you close your eyes
and you open your eyes the next day
you can't you can't take back everything
that you've done it's done
we have a finite amount of time people
live this life
on this earth as if they're going to
live forever and that's not the case
yeah right i'm not saying you have to
rush through things you have to try
you know you have to stress yourself out
the fact that you're going to die but
if you know that these days are spent
right
shouldn't you try to spend those days
not productive
but but being happy and kind of reaching
your own personal potential
and that could be just about anything
because me biking today for two hours is
not a waste of my time
that made me happy today i'm so jealous
of you that you biked
yeah but then i gotta work and edit two
videos after this i'll be up to like 1am
2am
so it's you know there's a give and take
for me well that's the thing like
not that i want your life i get to
choose what i get yeah
and you know you have a different work
lifestyle than i do obviously you know
and
it has really made me think like what
really does make me happy and
is what i'm doing worth
what i want to do like i have you know i
have goals and i have
purpose that i want to achieve and i'm
just looking back and saying
well those things are still possible but
why am i not doing it
and what are my excuses and you know
when i
told myself let's give it a try and do
some other things that i know that makes
me happy sure enough it's like
it it it brings so much joy
and it just
i guess i don't know it's just a turning
point for me again that
but i wake up a lot of the times not
feeling happy though
like even right now nothing's really
going on for me
like i have this podcast which i enjoy
because people listen to it and that's
the joy that i get
it's when people listen to this podcast
they say that it helps them get through
the day it makes them happy and makes
them smile
that's my joy right but my personal
goals
are kind of on hold right now because
even i don't know what i want to do
before it was the film like i was doing
the film
before it was stand up what's my goal
now you know what my goal is now is
literally just to be happy
like i i that's that's just my
overarching goal but i don't have a
personal set goal right now so
sometimes i have to struggle with that
every day right
and i think that's good like to have
that struggle of
trying to find out what it is i'm just
always doing something though yeah you
know
like i that's the thing that's what i
want to do i can't do anything else
is how i feel yeah because i'm
because of the nature of this pandemic
and my work it's just that that's how i
feel every day and
it really draws the life out of it of
course it takes away your spirit
right like yeah yeah it does
so you know but i think just
understanding that
and always thinking about you know it's
only been recent
and i love my therapist because she's
the one who is giving me a lot of like
hope i think or you know making me
realize there's still hope
of figuring out how to you know have my
quote-unquote work-life balance yeah
yeah
well you know i wonder how it is for
everybody else out there and how
quarantine really tested their own
personal relationships and their
thoughts about themselves and their
lives
because it was it was hard for everybody
um
some people came out stronger a lot of
people i know broke up i know
a lot of people were they haven't broken
up yet we have not
yet thank you thank you for the vote of
confidence
you know everything is a work in
progress right
and the good thing is because of therapy
i feel like we're stronger than we were
before
like we don't really fight as much it's
been since february
march april february march april maybe
two three months we've maybe had like a
few
few disagreements here but i feel like
your communication now is
it's it's on another level really like
you talk through your thoughts now where
i can understand you
oh yeah so i don't get angry now now you
could really
talk to me about how you feel oh i'm
glad you understand that and it helps me
like
rationalize what you're feeling you know
before we end this podcast let me just
give you this great story
so marielle and i have always had this
struggle of you know
she was talking about her own personal
self-worth so there are times because
number one
i didn't grow up in a household where
words of affirmation are needed for you
to feel good you kind of find that for
yourself
that that's something that she craves
for that's something that she needs it's
something that i've been learning to to
give to her more often right
um we found out that there was a small
discrepancy in our relationship
about how we value money versus physical
labor right
now what i mean by this is this is a
representation of effort
so to break that down even further um
she says that some she told me that she
feels that sometimes i shove money in
her face
and i was kind of thrown off by that i
go what do you mean i've never ever
shoved my money in your face at all like
i've never ever said look at how much
money i make
you don't make anything i've never ever
in my life would ever do that
right because it's a terrible thing to
ever say i've never done that so i
didn't know what she meant by that
and what she meant was that she feels
that sometimes that in
in lieu of me kind of fixing things that
i could do with my own hands i tend to
use money to fix these problems
and for her that felt that her effort is
not equivalent to the money that i make
right and what i was telling her is the
opposite
the value of somebody's effort in a
relationship and this is how i view it
anyways
let's just say this and we used an
example that we got into an argument
about a couple years ago
where she wanted me to help clean up the
house
and i said forget it i'm not going to
help you clean up the house because no
matter what no matter how i clean it
it's not going to be good enough
and if you're stressed and i'm stressed
let me just pay for a cleaner to come up
once a month or whenever we need her to
her or he and
they'll clean this whole place up and
she said no i want you to clean it up
and i got really
pissed and i'm like no like i'm what the
hell is the problem
and i think what happened there was that
it made me made her feel like i was
undermining her effort
right it's like oh if you just don't
want it you can always fix it with money
yeah
you know and then what i was telling her
is actually the exact opposite
your effort is always going to be valued
10 times more than the money that i use
to fix a problem
because i use the money to help clean up
this place
because i lack something that's allowing
me to help you that no matter how i help
you it's not going to work
so the only way i can solve it is
because i do have the financial
stability to help us out
so your effort is always going to be
here and my money to solve that problem
is always going to be here
and this is by the way the first time
i've ever had to ever heard him talk
about this
but it's also because this is the first
time you actually communicated
because before it was why can't you just
be nice
you know perhaps so it allowed us to
open up and have this conversation
so you know that's where this thing kind
of blew my mind i was like she always
thought that her effort was beneath the
the money that i was using to solve this
problem but it was never that way it's
like this
if she and i had a kid right if we have
a child
she's over here feeding the kid um
teaching the kid how to walk she's
giving them emotional support
but i'm working and i put the clothes on
their back and
the food in their mouth that [ __ ] that
doesn't matter
it matters that the person who is
present taking care of this child
the money is supplemental because of the
help that you need to raise the child
yeah so your effort it will always be
here and the money will be here
yeah you know i think and i'm i
appreciate you saying that
because um i have actually two
therapists
i have the one that i talk online and
actually my
personal trainer is actually another
therapist
because um that was the one thing that i
kept talking
i kept bringing up or it was stuck in my
mind she was like is some
is something wrong and i was like well
and i brought it up and she's like
i brought up the whole you know like i
feel like my value is just very
under-appreciated and she's like
what are you gonna talk about that and i
usually she doesn't bring it up
say like with that kind of suggestion
but i was like i think it's time
i think it's time i think time would
have been like five years ago
well it wouldn't it wouldn't have come
out like that collectively
yeah um because it was what i decided to
do
um since i was taking therapy is that i
would hold it in
and kind of remember these moments of
like is it a pattern
is it something that i'm doing you know
just to make sure that i'm not reacting
and telling him something out of just
emotion like for david he's all about
data
and i suck at remembering things but
when i hold it in
and i told myself i have to remember
this like i ended up remembering it so i
was able to bring up examples because
david loves to bring
no loves to hear or he has to know
examples to understand what i'm saying
too and it doesn't have to be anything
big either i just need something to chew
on yeah so if it's
and i don't like commands and the reason
why i don't like commands is because
that's how i was spoken to as a child my
whole life
it's do this don't ask do this don't ask
so now since i know how david doesn't
like to be treated
and i know how his brain works in a
sense of like that kind of communication
i
knew that i couldn't tell him what to do
which is
by default i already knew that but i
also need to bring up examples
and talk in in a very monotone manner
so that there's no emotion to it and i
have to wait because
um the reason of the waiting part is so
that i
don't bring emotion to the conversation
and so
it would take some time to bring it but
um
i think there was like solitude examples
where um
this conversation did work one was about
the value and one
was another thing that wasn't um in
the car uh no it was in the bedroom oh
i think we were just very like mellow
about it yeah um
because that's how i want to communicate
and i think like before the the question
i think me asking her why would set her
off but then i need the why
but i didn't know why yeah and it was
through therapy conversations over and
over again where i'm just like
sometimes i even have big eyes out of
nowhere i'm like whoa that's what i was
really thinking about and then like i
would say out loud like that and then
therapists were like
yeah it's it's some [ __ ] man like i'm
telling you
it really helped us out a lot i would
highly recommend it
whatever you're advertising i highly
recommend it it's some good stuff man
like i uh it really saved our
relationship because like i said
i and i've expressed before too how i
don't like commands because
growing up in my household my my dad was
very much
or my mom was just do it and don't ask
why why are you asking why you're
talking back
when really it's curiosity and i just i
just need something
you know it's not defiance it's
i need rationale and i don't need a lot
of it
but you know why can't you be nice
is is kind of reminding my parents you
know it was like oh
how do i wrap my head around this
because even something like today i'm in
a bad mood
and i don't know why but you're
triggering me right now so give me some
space
that's demanding give me some space yeah
but the y is there
you know well you could tell me to give
you space that's your space
you have every right to say that you
know that's your body your space you
tell me to give you space i need to give
you space
you're in my space give me my space yeah
and say hey
and i asked you why what's going on and
you go i'm just in a really off mood i
don't know why yet but you're pissing me
off
and i need to and then i'm like i don't
want to see your ugly face yeah and then
i'm just like oh what a [ __ ]
i'll just walk away and i'll just deal
with it right but if it was just like
why aren't you being nice you're so mean
then i'm like
what the [ __ ] you know like what the
hell is going on
i mean that will still come i think you
are always mean because you're on the
spectrum for me
but
but yeah i think uh i think i think it
has gotten better
i hope i hope we find our happiness
i found my happiness i hope you find
your personality fine i'll
i hope i find i know my personal
happiness i just hope i could pursue it
yeah well guys that wraps up this
episode of the genius brain podcast
you can find mariel at marielle
underscore underscore
song and um find everything that she
does there
she's working on a children's book right
now which is going to [ __ ] smash
the concept the idea of it is amazing
kids are going to learn so much from it
um be prepared for that uh next year
what the
heck i'm putting your time on why are
you putting this cause you keep sitting
on it so i gotta give you some pressure
so next year she's gonna be having that
out for you guys
so stay tuned for that and then we'll
see you all next time
thursdays and sundays everybody peace
bye